with every single variant
there's x you know that there's very
i would say
outside of
arguably a very flawed system there's a
lot of incredible scientific and
engineering work being done in
constantly developing new like antiviral
drugs
uh new
of new vaccines to deal with the
variants so they're happily being
a capitalist machine
and uh
it's very difficult to know what to do
with that
and let's just put this in perspective
for folks the best-selling drug in the
world has been humira for a number of
years it's uh
approved for the treatment of rheumatoid
arthritis and eight other indications uh
and it's sold about 20 billion dollars
uh globally
over the past few years it it leveled
out it peaked at that level
pfizer
expects to sell 65 billion dollars of
vaccine in the first two years of the
pandemic
so this is by far
the biggest selling and most profitable
drug that's ever been come along
can i ask you a difficult question here
in the fog that we're operating in here
on the pfizer
biontech
vaccine
what was done well
and what was done badly that you can
see now
it seems like we'll know
more decades from now
yes
but now in the fog of today
with the 65 billion dollars
flying around
where where do you land
so
we're going to get to
what i think is one of the key problems
with the pharmaceutical industry model
in the united states about being profit
driven
so
in 2016 the nih did the key
infrastructure work
to make mrna uh vaccines
uh that gets left out of the discussion
a lot and pfizer biontech actually paid
royalties
voluntarily to the nih i don't know how
much it was i don't think it was a whole
lot of money but i think they wanted to
avoid the litigation that moderna got
itself into
by just taking that 2016 knowledge and
having that be the foundation of their
product
so pfizer took that
and they did um their r d they paid for
their r d having received
that technology
and when they got the genetic code from
china
about the vaccine about the virus they
very quickly made a vaccine and the
vaccine works and president trump to his
credit
launched operation warp speed and just
threw money at the problem they just
said
we we spent five times more per person
than the eu early on just pay them
whatever they want let's just get this
going and americans were vaccinated uh
more quickly
we paid a lot of money the one mistake
that i think the federal government made
was they were paying these guaranteed
fortunes
and they didn't require
that the companies participate
in a program to do global vaccinations
they so the companies doing their
business model
distributed the vaccines where they
would make the most money and obviously
they would make the most money in the
first world and almost all i think
eighty-five percent of the vac vaccines
early on
went to the first world and very
very few vaccinations went to the third
world
so
what happened is
the
there was such a low vaccination rate in
may of 2021
there was all hands on deck cry for help
from the world trade organization
the world health organization
the imf and the world bank
made a plea
for 50 billion dollars so that we could
get to 40 vaccination rate in the third
world by the end of 2021
and it was unrequited
nobody answered
and now africa has about a 8.9
vaccination rate and india is coming up
but it's been very low the problem with
all this
is
i believe those mrna vaccines are
excellent vaccines
but if we leave the third world
unvaccinated
we're going to have a constant supply of
variants of kovid that are going to come
back into the united states and harm
americans exactly like delta and omicron
have
so we've made a great drug
it
reduces the risk of mortality in
americans who get it by a lot
but we're not doing what we need to do
to protect americans from omicron you
don't have to be an idealist and worry
about global vaccine equity if you're
just
ordinary selfish people like most of us
are and you're worried about the health
of americans you would ensure
global vaccine distribution let me just
make one more point
that 50 billion dollars that was
requested by the four organizations back
in may of 2021
32
billionaires made 50 billion dollars
from the vaccines at that point
took it into their private wealth
so what had been taken this enormous
amount of money that had been taken into
private wealth was enough to do
what those organizations said needed to
be done to prevent the sub-variants from
coming back and doing what they're doing
so the money was there but how does the
motivation the money-driven motivation
of big pharma lead to that um
that that kind of allocation of vaccines
because they can make more money in the
united states they're going to
distribute their vaccines where they can
make the most money all right is there
a malevolent aspect to this
where
boy i
i don't like saying this but
that they don't see it as a huge problem
that variants will come back to the
united states i think it's the issue we
were talking about
earlier on where they're in a different
culture and their culture is that their
moral obligation as milton friedman
would say
is to maximize the profits that they
return to shareholders and don't think
about
the bigger picture the collateral damage
don't think about the collateral and
also kind of believe
convince yourself
that if we give in to this
capitalist machine in this very narrow
sense of capitalism
that in the end they'll do the most good
this kind of belief that like if we just
maximize profits
we'll do the most good yeah that's an
orthodoxy of
several decades ago and i don't think
people can really say that in good faith
when you're talking about
uh vaccinating the third world so we
don't get hurt it's a little bit hard to
make the argument that the world's a
better place because the profits of the
investors went up yeah but at the same
time
it's
i i think that's a belief you can hold
i i mean i've interacted with a bunch of
folks that kind of it's the
i don't want to mischaracterize iron
rand okay i respect a lot of people but
there's is a belief that can take hold
if i just focus on this particular
maximization
it will do the most good for the world
the problem is when you choose what to
maximize and you put blinders on it's
too easy to start making
gigantic mistakes that have a big
negative impact on society so it really
matters what you're maximizing right and
if we had a true democracy
and everybody had one vote
everybody got decent information and had
one vote
and rand's position would get some votes
but not many
and it would be way out voted by the
common people
you